foreign
ERS look to set it in front if Andrew King
couldn't come up with a kind he's a turn the other
way and here they come Matthias Michelli a little
pull-up move Michelli gets a shot away scores
might have been deflected and the coyotes with a
one-nothing lead early tonight at the mullet fired
in front of the net the coyotes go back the other
way it's a three on two Miceli buys himself some
time draws some Defenders to him and he puts it
right through the middle of the ice the shooting
Lane I believe that goes off of somebody in front
I think that's Kane that actually redirects that
puck in his own net how do you try to defend him
well you obviously take away the middle of the
ice that's all you can hope for you know they're
gonna get their looks you're gonna count on your
goaltender come up with some big stops but don't
let them go east west so Bouchard will set it
up for Nugent Hopkins goes across the front just
like that they score Zach Hyman set up by Connor
McDavid and it's 1-1 inside and this is why you
can't take penalties watch the puck movement it's
going to go down low right across that seam and
back again through the scene and if you let that
pass go that's one thing but then you gotta pick
up on the other side and the coyotes certainly do
not do that Hyman throws a stick on the ice and
that's the old shot pass right there [Applause]
Keller it'll drop out High here's Lawson Kraus
side of the net Hayden backhander up high rebound
him
[Music] but he scored a lot of his goals
this year right there in front nice little
play there back [Applause] I believe off
of Campbell on the second chance he gets
hanging around hacking and walking there's
the first shot gets it right back and Oilers
he is at home
now Butte stag great look just hit the outside
of the net a shot by Bouchard he ties it
the defenseman Evan Bouchard and it's 2-2
this time and even sweats Duke's Dad don't miss
a time or two brings it to the net drives hard
beautiful play back to Bouchard and he throws
this up high watch this shot by Bouchard over
the blocker right over the left shoulder
of Kerala malka that is an absolute Dart
it'll have to wait for Schmaltz to get
on side now Keller with it brings it in
Travis Boyd locked up there Keller
tried to keep his own he can two on
one the other way yeah Mark a
little drop nurse shoot score
Darnell nurse
and it's 3-2 Edmonton so they've got an even
strength goal a power play goal and a shorty
here in the opening period absolute missile
and turn over here on the blue line Clayton
Keller couldn't grab that puck out of mid-air
Yamamoto makes a beautiful pass the nurse who
have Clayton Keller all over him and still gets
that puck off and he throws that right over the
glove of Coralville malka another Darton
two defensemen now for the Edmonton Oilers
in the National Hockey lay that's a whole
other animal and you train for it you eat
you feed your body and you work on all the
things that you need to downstairs Todd walls
will get it out and he clears all the way back
home couldn't get it out stolen Krauss across
Michelli shoots and it's underneath camel and he's
able to cover up how to slide it across for Travis
Boyd and denied and Buicks down the other way
for PoGo and now Butte stat in front
couldn't finish it wrap around in front
this one's going to be covered by the milk in a
real good look for the former Kane Warren Vogel
Leon dry side on it's brought right back
[Applause] he can't believe it nurse
takes a big hit there by Brown and
how did that stay out my goodness that
was Hyman all alone off the left pad off
the arm of Kerala Malkin somehow he keeps his
out my goodness what a stop oh my's Advantage
any way you can get it that's the most important
thing as we've seen this year with the Coyote's
here at the moment 2011-4 are the coyotes here
on home ice dry saddle with a shot he scores
well that's one corel's going to want to have back
Tyson 4-2 Edmonton and Leon tricidal at it again
we'll take a look at it [Applause]
oh yeah that was just a quick shot
maybe through a little bit of a of a screen
not sure if that was redirected off the boot of
valamaki are not maybe a better look
coming up here but the Evans and Oilers
kalamaki across Josh Brown [Applause] play back
in behind the net how he's going right back
tonight with the 4-3 defense he's crossed
with a shot and Matt puts it home but Tim
how about those hands second of
the night and it's a one goal game
unbelievable the counties keep this Puck alive
McBain back to cross pacelli right there in front
big juicy rebound off of Campbell look at that
dirty toe drag and Micelli puts it in I thought he
put it in the four on the backhand but he puts
it in on the forehand right there just tucks
try to drop it there Schmaltz into the corner and
behind the net and around now balamaki continues
[Applause]
in a minute and there's the shot
by Keller again the rebound hanging
around paired Hayden where he's made
a living this year nobody picks him up
who starts all over him right there
and he's looking the wrong way and
Barrett Hayden is second of the
hockey game his 17th of the season
what a move and want an effort
Barrett Hayton two goals of a
span of 58 seconds identical to what
we saw yesterday afternoon Bouchard
right to the Line pass away by Josh Brown
coyotes Connor they bring it in McBain with
a shot rebound right there and he can't buy
it for the hat trick way back on high Bouchard
now McDavid into the corner Newton Hopkins
the McDavid working around Fanning on it was
dry side Brown out of the box so it's a five on
four for pretty much a full two Bouchard with a
shot rebound they score Eugene Hopkins and the
Oilers lead it five to four come at you every
time that puck goes back to the point everyone
goes right down to that blue paint there's two
three white jerseys right there in front of that
blue paint and Nugent Hopkins great set of mips
it's a couple whacks that this one just a little
Chip Shot over the left pad Blocker of America
I know Keller in front Michelli gets it back Crow
so he fanned on it that was the look they wanted
and a second to go and the Oilers
are going to survive and uh